[Music]
several minors have testified in derek
sheldon's trial about what they saw the
night george floyd died
law and crimes antoinette levy is here
to tell us why the state has called
so many young people to the stand
anjanet
brian all of those children testified
that seeing this was difficult for them
it was very traumatic
so you can imagine that testifying about
it would be as well
but it's quite possible that if derek
chauvin is convicted the testimony of
those children
could have an impact on his sentence
first of all would you tell us how old
you are
nine at that time memorial day last year
how old were you then
17. one by one children took the stand
to testify about what they saw the night
george floyd died
tell us what happened after you saw the
ambulance come
he asked the emblems had to push him off
of them did you notice anything about
what mr strauben was doing
with his body yes at one point i saw
him put more and more weight onto him
prosecutors filed a notice last year to
seek an upward sentencing departure if
chauvin is convicted
meaning they'll ask for a longer
sentence than allowed by law
the fact that the crime alleged happened
in front of children
is one of the reasons why a longer
sentence may be sought
the judge can depart downward but he
cannot depart upward
unless a jury makes certain findings
former hennepin county public defender
mary moriarty says if chauvin is
convicted
and the jury finds children were present
judge cahill could increase the prison
sentence but it's not a given
of course if the judge gives an upward
departure
that would be a ground for appeal and
the state wants to make sure they have a
really good record
establishing each basis for a departure
the reason we're even discussing this is
because minnesota
is one of those states that has
sentencing guidelines which means
there's a range of sentences that can be
given
while a lot of other states have fixed
sentences for certain crimes
or at least minimums brian thanks ange
bryant and terry are here let me ask
both of you
starting with you brian the children's
testimony is very authentic isn't it
absolutely brian ross it's hard for any
defense attorney
to be able to cross-examine a minor or
even someone that was
a minor at the time you can't really say
their credibility is off maybe their
ability to perceive things is off
because they're young but i think a
really strong point is at the end of the
day the prosecution's gonna be able to
say
even a nine-year-old knew this was wrong
and that's something that i don't think
eric nelson or derek shoving can argue
against
and terry eric nelson did do much of a
job in challenging their testimony did
he
he did not he didn't even cross-examine
two of them especially the nine-year-old
and i think he knew better and plus the
fact that most of the testimony
that these miners gave were really
corroborating
information that they already knew for
instance the fact that
chauvin's knee was on floyd's neck and
the fact that
he did not move his knee until the
medics came to
ask him to move away so that information
was already known
i think eric nelson took a calculated
guess and thought
it was better not to look as though he
is in any way badgering
these young women imagine that bottom
line this means that the sentence for
uh derek shoving if he's found guilty
could be enhanced
yeah that's right ryan and there were
some other reasons
that the prosecution cited for asking
the judge for an
upward variance that included the fact
that derek chovin
was somebody in a position of authority
a position of power he was a police
officer and
they say he abused that authority and
they also said that they
the officers including chauvin treated
floyd with particular cruelty
because he was handcuffed at the time
that this happened and you could tell
quickly the trauma the children suffered
just watching a man die in front of them
yeah most definitely you could just hear
it in their voices it was so
sad to hear them talk about this and
especially darnella the young woman who
took that viral video she spoke of how
she'd stay
she stays up at night sometimes thinking
about this and apologizing for not doing
more
all right very effective testimony
thanks antoinette imagine that levy
coming up on law and crime daily new
video of george floyd
inside that store we've got it here
plus an eyewitness breaks down as he
watches the video of the incident
he tried to warn george floyd to
cooperate with police
[Music]
you